Bonjour!
L’été se termine, et j’espère que si
vous aimez la mer vous avez profité de la
mer. Moi pas du tout.
Parce que l’Écosse!
Si vous aviez manqué le début, cette vidéo
est la suite d’une première partie, c’est
logique, qui abordait la mer inconnue, les
créatures mystiques qui la peuplent et le
fait que la mer fait peur. En gros.
-Vous la retrouverez à la fin du générique
et pouvez aller la voir maintenant, ou après,
y’a pas vraiment d’ordre puisqu’on parlera
d’autres thèmes aujourd’hui.
-L’absence d’Histoire Antique dans l’épisode
qui commence me laisse sans voix.
-Vraiment? Trop bien.
-Effectivement aujourd’hui on va plutôt
aller du XVIIe au XXe siècle, il y aura donc
même assez peu d’histoire médiévale…
-ATTENDS UN PEU
-Alors c’est parti!
Déjà pour prendre la mer, il faut des bateaux.
-Waouh. 2 mois de recherches hein.
-Et il se trouve que ces bateaux sont longtemps
inaptes à aller très loin: jusqu’au
XIIe siècle, à part avec les navires vikings,
il est impossible de traverser l’Atlantique
et ses vagues pour les européens. Ce n’est
qu’à partir des XIIIe et XIVe siècle qu’apparaissent
de plus grands navires, plus solides.
-Au XVe siècle est inventée la caravelle
qui est à la fois maniable et solide, parfait
pour traverser l’Atlantique jusqu’en Asie.
Euh, en Amé… Améquoi?
-Mais pendant longtemps au MA, les marins
utilisent aussi principalement la navigation
à vue: on n’utilise pas d’astrolabes,
pourtant connus et bien pratiques, mais des
quadrants plus aléatoires. Le temps est mesuré
grâce à des sabliers d’une demi heure,
les ampolletas, et des cordes à nœuds permettent
d’évaluer la distance parcourue. Tout ça
reste assez imprécis, surtout que les cartes
côtières sont encore largement incomplètes.
-La veue est carrément une unité de distance
en mer, déterminée par la visibilité d’une
voile sur l’horizon. Du coup les tempêtes
font d’autant plus peur qu’on voit plus
rien.
-Ensuite, on a vu dans l’épisode précédent
que peu de marins avaient vraiment une vocation
pour ce métier, parce que la mer faisait
peur. C’est aussi parce que les conditions
de travail sont absolument horribles.
L’équipage est serré. Il dort sur des
paillasses, des matelas ou plus tard des hamacs,
dans l’entrepont au milieu des marchandises
et des câbles. Seul le capitaine a sa cabine,
quand il ne la loue pas à d’autres passagers.
L’entrepont est humide, encombré par les
animaux embarqués pour servir de repas au
cours du voyage, alors quand le temps le permet
les marins dorment même carrément sur le
pont à la belle étoile.
En plus, les escales sont rares. Elles sont
l’occasion de racheter des vivres et des
animaux: les rations dont on a gardé la
trace semblent montrer que les marins mangeaient
suffisamment, mais leur alimentation était
très monotone. Et les aliments sont difficiles
à conserver, surtout vers les tropiques.
-Pour oublier cette malbouffe, on boit et
on fume, tellement que les capitaines craignent
une pénurie d’alcool ou de tabac qui pourrait
entraîner une mutinerie.
Même si vu l’état des cales de ce navire,
l’absence de rhum serait pas ma principale
préoccupation.
La consommation d'alcool est telle qu'au début
du Xxe siècle, un commandant de marine déclare
être «absolument convaincu que les neuf
dixièmes des marins qui sont enlevés par
la mer ne le sont qu'à cause de leur état
d'ivresse».
Une autre difficulté de la vie de marin,
et de beaucoup d'autres métiers d'ailleurs,
est le caractère répétitif des tâches
à accomplir qui en plus d'être dures ne
sont pas vraiment épanouissantes.
Ça peut entraîner des problèmes de santé
tels que les courbatures, rhumatismes, hernies
ou maladies pulmonaires, ou accidents de travail,
amputations à cause de caisses mal arrimées,
de chutes du mât...
Dans beaucoup de registres du XVIIIe siècle
on trouve des marins de 40 à 60 ans estropiés,
sourds ou aveugles.
-La surdité, c'est surtout le domaine des
canonniers, à force de tirer au canon, et
les problèmes de vue sont dus à la forte
luminosité en mer et au sel.
-En plus de ça, on manque d'eau douce, donc
d'hygiène, donc on ne manque pas du tout
de maladies à bord. Les marins sont souvent
trop crevés pour effectuer des tâches superflues
comme désinfecter le navire, et chopent donc
facilement des vermines ou pire.
Les maladies les plus courantes sont la typhoïde,
liée à l'absorption d'eau ou d'aliments
contaminés par des matières fécales humaines.
-Le typhus, également une maladie liée à
l'hygiène, se transmet par les poux.
-Le scorbut est une carence en vitamine C,
particulièrement courant chez les marins
au long court, qui provoque un affaiblissement,
de la fièvre, des pertes de dents...
-Nos chers marins sont cependant sauvés par
la découverte de la cristallisation de la
vitamine C dans l'eau de vie, au XVIIIe siècle,
qui permet de créer des «punchs antiscorbutiques»
parfaits pour l'apéro sur le pont.
Et puis y'a toujours les maladies vénériennes,
qu'on peut choper lors des escales, mais pas
seulement!
D'ailleurs tous ces risques rencontrés par
les marins sont illustrés sous la forme de
tatouages, puisque c'est largement par les
marins que les tatouages arrivent en Europe
à partir du XVIIIe siècle. Se faire tatouer
les dangers de la mer est aussi une manière
de s'en prémunir, comme une sorte de symbole
protecteur.
A partir du XIXe siècle, avec l'arrivée
de la machine à vapeur, les conditions de
vie s'améliorent un peu: les escales se
multiplient, ce qui permet de manger plus
de légumes, et on risque moins de tomber
du haut des voiles quand il n'y en a plus.
Mais on peut toujours s'exposer à des explosions
de chaudières, des maladies pulmonaires à
cause des vapeurs, des problèmes de vue à
cause de l'obscurité dans la salle des machines...
Les navires restent dangereux, jusqu'à aujourd'hui:
en France, entre 2006 et 2015, on compte 176
accidents de travail mortel chez les marins
dont 133 dans le domaine de la pêche.
Ces conditions de travais il plutôt déplaisantes
entraînent parfois des mutineries, parfois
très impressionnantes:
Par exemple en 1797 a lieu une mutinerie à
bord de la HMS Hermione, un navire britannique,
car le capitaine Pigot aimait bien fouetter
ses marins. Une pratique tout à fait acceptable
si les marins sont consentants, certes, mais
cela ne nous regarde pas. Et c'était pas
le cas.
Les mutineries peuvent aussi être de simples
conflits de travail qui trouvent une solution
pacifique, et ne se déroulent pas toujours
à bord mais parfois pendant une escale, avant
le départ... Les raisons principales peuvent
être le manque de rations, la cruauté des
officiers, ou la remise en cause de leurs
compétences.
C'est le cas lors de l'expédition d'Henry
Hudson, en 1611. Il donne son nom à la baie
d'Hudson mais incite son équipage à continuer
l'exploration toujours plus loin, ce que l'équipage
finit par refuser. Il est alors jeté sur
un canot avec son fils et quelques hommes,
et meurt très certainement.
Et enfin, la dernière grosse difficulté
rencontrée en mer est le risque de tempête
et de naufrage!
Les deux vont souvent ensemble, mais pas toujours.
Si on part dans les statistiques, au XVIIIe
siècle en France, 60% des naufrages ont lieu
entre novembre et février et les 2/3 ont
lieu la nuit, ce qui nous donne une idée
des causes de ces naufrages.
-Il fait moche et il fait noir.
-Même quand les tempêtes commencent en journée,
la catastrophe se produit souvent à la nuit
tombée, surtout lorsque le navire se trouve
près d'un littoral.
Les naufrages au large existent, mais la majorité
a lieu près des littoraux voire même à
la sortie du port pour les plus doués. Pour
vous donner une idée, au XVIIIe siècle,
un tiers de la flotte de pêche basque coule
entre Bayonne et Saint-Jean de Luz. Sur cette
petite distance là! Là!
Au XIXe siècle, la Manche et la Bretagne
sont les côtes françaises les plus dangereuses.
Les causes des naufrages, en dehors des tempêtes,
peuvent aussi être humaines, comme pour le
Titanic et le Costa Concordia ou matérielles
si le navire a un problème.
Parfois même l'erreur est humaine mais ne
vient pas du bateau: en 1786, un navire
approchant du port de Marseille ne voit pas
le phare allumé et décide de tirer un coup
de canon pour dire «coucou, on est là»,
et effectivement les gardiens du phare avaient
juste oublié de l'allumer.
-Ce qui aurait pu être un peu dangereux.
-Et enfin, la principale cause est la météo:
tempête, brouillard, orage... Toutes ces
circonstances auraient provoqué entre 1824
et 1962 13 000 naufrages et 1,7 million de
morts.
Imaginez le bordel. C'est la tempête, on
ne voit pas grand chose, et personne ne sait
quoi faire.
-Le capitaine essaie bien de donner des ordres,
parce que c'est son rôle, mais il reste plus
grand monde pour l'écouter.
-Surtout que certains hommes se sont déjà
jetés à la mer, d'autres essaient de s'emparer
des chaloupes, et les plus pragmatiques profitent
de leurs derniers instants pour vider les
réserves d'alcool des officiers.
-Certains matelots se mettent à prier, soit
Dieu, soit la mer dans un sursaut de paganisme,
promettent de partir en pèlerinage s'ils
survivent et oublieront vite leur promesse
une fois le danger passé...
Car quand même, tout le monde ne meurt pas
lors d'un naufrage. La moyenne est de 7 à
8 victimes, les catastrophes massives comme
le Titanic sont rares.
A partir du XVIIIe siècle les récits de
naufrages deviennent très populaires, et
constituent souvent l'élément déclencheur
ou perturbateur d'un roman: dans les Malheurs
de Sophie par exemple, où le naufrage du
navire est un peu le twist facile de milieu
de récit, ou dans Paul et Virginie, qui est
inspiré d'un vrai naufrage et qui permet
de montrer l'exil, la survie, toutes ces épreuves
qui font trépigner les lecteurs!
Les naufrages apparaissent donc dans la littérature,
mais de vrais récits de naufrage peuvent
constituer des livres à part entière:
les journaux de bord sont publiés, parfois
sous forme de compilations, et forcément
quand quelque chose devient populaire il y
a aussi une récupération politique de ces
récits.
C'est le cas avec le naufrage du Vengeur du
Peuple en 1794, dont l'équipage aurait eu
la bonne idée de crier «vive la République»
en mourant. De bien braves citoyens. Une maquette
du navire est exposée au Panthéon, les noms
des marins sont inscrits sur ses murs, c'est
la grosse fête.
A l'inverse, avec le naufrage de la Méduse
en 1816, on est plutôt dans le scandale politique
et la dénonciation de la traite des noirs.
On retrouve aussi ces naufrages en peinture,
surtout à partir du XVIIIe, en musique à
l'époque baroque... Bref, du XVIIIe au XIXe,
à part les marins, ces rabat-joie, tout le
monde aime les naufrages.
Mais la mer n'est pas que le propre des marins.
La mer n'est d'ailleurs pas propre tout court,
mais c'est un autre problème. Il y a des
tas de gens qui dépendent de la mer ou qui
font face à ses risques, sans jamais mettre
un pied dans l'eau. Alors tout de suite un
point sur la vie sur les littoraux.
-Et c'est parti pour encore plus de dangers
venus de la mer.
-Oui parce que quand une tempête a lieu au
large, étrangement, elle ne s'arrête pas
à la frontière comme le nuage de Tchernobyl.
Il arrive que les ondes de tempête menacent
les régions les plus exposées comme le Mont
Saint Michel, les Flandres...
-Si on part dans un cours de géographie physique,
je déménage.
-Soit, des dates. En 1042, une série de tempêtes
provoque des inondations en Flandre et en
Zélande. D'autres raz de marée sont rapportés
en Frise en 1218. Ça va pour les dates?
-Tu parles carrément de frises, alors oui,
ça va.
-Le raz de marée, ou tsunami, on ne sait
pas trop, le plus meurtrier en Europe est
celui de Lisbonne, le 1er novembre 1755, qui
tue entre 50 000 et 80 000 morts et est suivi
par un grand incendie de la ville.
-D'autres raz de marée sont bien plus thé
oriques mais font partie des légendes populaires,
comme la ville d'Ys: elle se serait trouvée
au large de Douarnenez, et aurait été engloutie
entre le Ive et le Ve siècle. Au XVIe siècle,
les pêcheurs racontent entendre régulièrement
les cloches de la ville sonner, car la ville
existerait toujours sous les eaux et ses habitants
y jouiraient d'une vie éternelle.
-D'après cette légende, Paris coulerait
aussi un jour car son nom signifierait «Pareille
à Ys». Ouais, les théories du complot,
c'est pas votre époque qui les a inventées.
Il arrive aussi que le danger arrive par la
mer, via les hommes qui naviguent dessus et
qui s'attaquent à la côte. Qu'on appelle
ces attaques raids ou razzias, elles sont
courantes dès l'Antiquité comme pour la
ville de Pise, attaquée en 193 par une flotte
de 40 000 hommes.
Souvent les pirates arrivent de nuit avec
des complices locaux, s'emparent de tout le
butin qu'ils peuvent et repartent.
-Parmi le butin, on trouve des hommes, qui
peuvent être vendus comme esclaves ou échangés
contre une rançon.
-Ces raids continuent sous les francs, les
saxons, les vikings... Avec l'avantage qu'ils
rentrent carrément à l'intérieur des terres,
grâce aux fleuves, donc ce ne sont plus seulement
les littoraux qui sont menacés. Mais on ne
va pas encore parler des vikings...
-Et pourquoi pas ?!
-On les a déjà vus...
-Regardez l'épisode 7, si vous voulez!
Bref, à partir du XVIe siècle les razzias
ont à nouveau lieu en Méditerranée, à
cause des navires ottomans ou barbaresques.Certaines
villes côtières attaquées perdent alors
entre 40 et 80% de leur population!
-Par exemple en 1798, à Carloforte, en Sardaigne,
1000 personnes sont capturées en une nuit
par un pirate originaire du coin.
-Et en cas de guerre, c'est pareil, c'est...
-Eh.
-Quoi, je parle!
-Du coup à Carloforte, ils étaient pas très...
Forte.
-...
-... Bref, la guerre!
-Ben, quand l'ennemi attaque par bateau, la
côte et les ports sont les premiers à trinquer.
Voilà.
Mais la mer, c'est aussi le meilleur moyen
de transport pour les virus, bactéries et
autres épidémies de toute sortes. On a déjà
parlé de la peste, épisode 16, mais on trouve
aussi le typhus, ou le choléra à partir
du XIXe siècle, venu d'Asie, la fièvre jaune
venue d'Afrique... Bref, pour les gens vivant
sur les littoraux, la mer est à la fois celle
qui leur permet de vivre et celle qui leur
permet de mourir prématurément. Des fois.
A l'inverse, c'est parfois les gens de la
côte qui sont un danger pour la mer. On a
parlé des naufrages un peu plus haut, mais
si ces naufrages étaient provoqués volontairement
par les locaux pour piller les navires?
-Ce serait vraiment méchant.
-Et c'est vraiment peu avéré, mais les idées
reçues ont la vie dure.
En Bretagne, à partir du XVIIe siècle, la
croyance en des pilleurs de mer se répand.
Il s'agirait d'habitants des environs qui
allumeraient des lanternes sur la tête d'une
vache et la feraient marcher le long de la
côte pour faire croire à un navire. Comme
ça les marins, croyant qu'ils étaient plus
au large qu'ils pensaient, s'échoueraient
gentiment sur la plage et pillez jeunesse..
Cette croyance reste très répandue mais
pourtant, sur tous les naufrages recensés
entre le XVIIe et le XVIIIe siècle en Bretagne
un seul a lieu selon les marins à cause d'un
feu trompeur. Une fois échoués les marins
disent apercevoir deux inconnus sur la plage
dont l'un armé, mais les accusés disent
qu'ils étaient juste venus aider.
-J'ai juste voulu rendre service!
-En plus déjà une vache, même avec un feu
sur le dos, ça éclaire peu, et encore plus
s'il y a une tempête au large. Je dis des
conneries, ou...
-Non, non, c'est vrai. Par contre les pillages
après un naufrage existent bien. En 1768,
le capitaine de L'Espérance, échoué à
Penmarc'h, explique que les locaux sont venus
aider l'équipage... Avant d'embarquer le
coffre du navire, aussi. Fleur de Tonnerre
vers 33mn
Et quand il faut accueillir les naufragés
chez soi en attendant les secours, c'est pareil,
l'hospitalité est pas toujours au rendez-vous,
surtout que les marins peuvent très bien
s'échouer sur une côte déserte et mourir
de faim ou de froid, tout simplement.
La situation évolue progressivement, grâce
à une réglementation de 1698 qui interdit
de dépouiller les noyés, c'est sympa, et
avec le renforcement ds garde-côtes qui convainquent
de plus en plus les habitants des littoraux
qu'aid er les autres, c'est sympa aussi.
Mais parlons en, encore, des habitants des
littoraux: pendant que les marins du début
de l'épisode risquent leur vie au large,
la famille reste au port et c'est pas forcément
joyeux. Pendant que les proches attendent
en espérant que les marins vont bien rentrer
à bon port...
-Ha!
-Les conditions de vie de la famille sont
souvent difficiles, et s'accentuent en cas
de décès du marin. Il existe des métiers
accessibles aux femmes de marins, comme dentellière,
nourrice, pêcheuse à pied ou poissonnière,
ou encore avec le développement des conserveries
qui paient peu mais qui offrent au moins un
métier stable. Quoi qu'il en soit la mer
fait encore une fois intégralement partie
de la vie mais aussi de la mort des populations
côtières, qui ont toutes vécu au moins
un deuil à cause d'un marin perdu en mer.
Dans les années 1970, très récemment donc
par rapport à mes périodes habituelles,
une veuve de Douarnenez témoigne: «J'ai
perdu mon père en mère; j'ai perdu mes
cousins en mer. Je n'avais qu'un fils et j'ai
perdu mon fils en mer. Il avait 25 ans et
il était sur le Jules Verne. En septembre
1953. Je n'ai plus personne. Eh ben, j'ai
peur pour les autres... Car je sais qu'il
y a toujours quelqu'un sur l'eau».
On l'a donc vu, dans cet épisode et dans
le précédent: la mer est dangereuse, la
mer tue et donc elle fait peur. Alors pour
s'en protéger, des tas de moyens se mettent
en place, en allant de la protection par la
superstition aux systèmes d'assurances.
On retrouve beaucoup de moyens de se protéger
de la mer dans les symboles utilisés, les
ex-voto et les pratiques païennes.
Par exemple, durant l'Antiquité, il était
courant de répandre le sang d'un animal sur
le pont pour se mettre sous la protection
des dieux de la mer. Cette pratique survit
parfois longtemps: dans les ports de Ligurie,
il était courant jusqu'au XVIe siècle de
sacrifier un mouton blanc et de clouer sa
peau au mât du navire.
-Et sur les navires barbaresques du XVIIe,
on coupait le mouton en deux et on en jetait
une moitié à bâbord, l'autre à tribord.
-Entre autres pratiques païennes, on dit
que réciter un Notre Père inversé peut
permettre une bonne traversée, que rencontrer
une vieille fille ou un prêtre avant de prendre
la mer est un mauvais présage... Avec le
temps, les symboles protecteurs païens se
retrouvent sur les éléments du navire:
le gouvernail, l'ancre, et le plus souvent
la proue du navire qui est ornée d'un bélier,
d'une sirène... Le but des proues ornées
est à la base d'effrayer les mauvais esprits
et de protéger des dangers, avant de devenir
un moyen de reconnaissance.
Et puis la religion chrétienne se mêle de
la protection des mains à son tour: on
lit des prières lors du baptême du navire,
à partir du XIVe siècle et surtout au XIXe.
Ces cérémonies se retrouvent dans tous les
ports de pêche français et sont aussi attestées
avant le départ d'un navire. Le curé s'avance
alors vers la mer, trempe le manche de sa
croix dans l'eau et appelle à la protection
des navires qui la parcourront. Et what is
dead may never die.
En plus de tout ça, on construit des sanctuaires,
chapelles le plus souvent dédiés à Marie
ou simples croix près de la mer ou en haut
de falaises. C'est le cas de Notre Dame de
la garde de Marseille, par exemple. Comme
ça les marins peuvent aller prier et s'y
confesser avant le départ, ou les saluer
lorsqu'ils passent devant en bateau. Au retour
d'une tempête, ils y retournent en pèlerinage
et donnent une messe pour ceux qui se sont
noyés.
La dévotion va même parfois plus loin que
ça: des marins glissent des billets ou
talismans dans les anfractuosités de l'église
avant le départ, ou emportent des cierges,
pains bénits ou statues de la vierge avec
eux à bord pour les jeter par dessus bord
en cas de tempête. Ça valait bien la peine
de les emmener.
Ceux qu'on emmène à bord, c'est aussi les
prêtres, directement. A partir du XVIIIe
siècle les navires de guerre ont souvent
un aumônier qui prie surtout en cas de tempête.
S'il n'y a pas de prêtre à bord c'est le
capitaine qui le fait, ou les marins entre
eux.
Malgré l'importance grandissante de l’Église
dans les relations entre les hommes et la
mer, certaines pratiques restent teintées
de croyances plus anciennes:
-En Bretagne et en Normandie, on ouvre des
tombes fraîches durant la nuit du 1er au
2 novembre pour que les noyés puissent y
rentrer.
-Dans les cimetières existent aussi des «murs
des péris» où on pose les plaques des
disparus. Cette information n'a rien à voir
avec l'histoire antique, mais mon quota à
l'écran est plutôt bas dans cet épisode.
-Et enfin, je vous invite à vous renseigner
sur le rituel de la proëlla en Bretagne et
plus particulièrement sur l'île d'Ouessant,
lors de l'annonce d'un décès. Je vous mettrai
quelques liens en bas si vous voulez.
Après pour se protéger en cas de naufrage,
il existait aussi des méthodes bien plus
terre à terre, même si on est en mer:
les assurances.
Dès le XVIIe en Angleterre et le XVIIIe en
France, il existe des assurances sur la marchandise
des navires, qui garantissent les risques
d'avarie mais aussi de perte par tous les
moyens imaginables.
Lors de la préparation d'un voyage, les armateurs,
ceux qui possèdent le navire, ont recours
à des prêts «à la grosse aventure»,
qu'on appelle aussi «à retour de voyage»
ou «au risque, péril et fortune»:
en gros si quelque chose arrive au navire,
il n'aura rien à rembourser, et si tout se
passe bien il devra rendre la somme au prêteur
plus un intérêt. Il existe aussi des prêts
à simple ou double risque, un simple risque
compte juste un aller simple, un double risque
prend en compte l'aller et retour.
-Pour faciliter la navigation, il existe aussi
des contrats «de conserve» jusqu'au
XVIe siècle: les navires partent ensemble,
rentrent au port ensemble, soudés, unis.
C'est beau.
-A partir du XVIIe, on parle de convois, qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à 150 navires. C'est
beau, sauf quand tout le convoi se fait choper,
et c'est le cas en 1693 où une centaine de
navires du convoi de Smyrne sont détruits
pour une histoire de vengeance.
Car bien sûr les risques peuvent être une
tempête mais aussi la rencontre de pirates:
certains marins et passagers s'assurent aussi
contre le risque de capture, comme ça la
rançon est déjà prête à être versée
avant même le départ.
C'est aussi pour faire face aux risques maritimes
et au deuil des familles de marins qu'avance
la protection sociale:
Dès le XVIIe siècle est créée une Caisse
pour les invalides de la Marine Royale, qui
est ensuite étendue aux marins du commerce
et de la pêche.
Bon, la situation est pas géniale quand même,
mais dès 1791 les marins de la marine peuvent
prendre leur retraite à 50 ans et les pêcheurs
obtiennent aussi ce droit en 1823.
Il existe aussi des aides pour les veuves
et enfants de marins, comme l’École des
mousses, mais tout ça reste assez faible.
-Avant ça et pour compenser l'absence d'aide
de l’État, des charités et associations
de métier se mettent en place dès MON époque,
enfin on parle des périodes qui comptent.
-Oui enfin si on part sur les périodes qui
comptent, pour ce qui est du sauvetage en
mer c'est MON époque qui montre l'exemple.
Dès le premier siècle après JC, l'empereur
Claude ordonnait aux habitants des littoraux
de secourir les naufragés.
-Oui ben par la suite aussi on repêche les
gens! Non?
-Euh, oui, plusieurs ordonnances françaises
encouragent l'entraide et la solidarité:
en 1743 par exemple, il est ordonné aux communautés
littorales de porter une chaloupe de dix hommes
au moins au secours d'un navire naufragé.
Ce n'est qu'au XIXe siècle qu'apparaissent
les postes de surveillance, dans les villes
portuaires d'abord puis là où le tourisme
se développe. Genre en Méditerranée. Et
enfin, en 1895 apparaissent les navires-hôpitaux.
-Ce sont des navires où on soigne les gens.
-Merci pour cette information capitale. Ces
navires permettent de soigner de nombreux
marins au cours du Xxe siècle et voyagent
jusqu'au large du Canada et de l'Islande pour
accompagner les navires de pêche. Ils sont
finalement remplacés par le rapatriement
en avion ou hélicoptère, et disparaissent.
Et enfin, la protection contre la mer passe
aussi par la mise en place d'installations
sur la côte et de codes maritimes.
-Dès l'Antiquité, nous construisions des
tours de guet le long des côtes pour nous
protéger de l'ennemi.
-Ouais ben au Moyen-Âge aussi on faisait
ça, regardez Concarneau par exemple! C'est
autre chose qu'une tour côtière. Et puis
les gardes-côte, c'était dès Charlemagne.
-Sécuriser les côtes passe aussi par la
lutte contre les vagues, le sable et l'érosion,
avec le développement des jetées dans les
ports et la plantation d'oyats dans les dunes
à partir du XVIIIe siècle.
Pour faciliter la navigation, de nombreux
systèmes existent aussi: les phares, par
exemple, existent depuis le IIe siècle avant
J.C. On continue de trouver des tours à feu
sur toute la côte méditerranéenne durant
l'Antiquité, mais elles sont un peu délaissées
au MA
-Ah! Amateurs...
-... Et sont réhabilitées au XVIIe. A partir
du XVIIIe on invente même le système de
rotation qui permet d'identifier les phares,
selon le rythme de leur lumière, et les premiers
phares électrifiés apparaissent dans la
2e moitié du XIXe.
La mer peut donc sembler un sujet tout bête,
mais il peut être abordé de plein de manières
différentes. Ça fait un moment que j'ai
arrêté de choisir mes sujets par l'événementiel,
et que je m'intéresse plutôt aux pratiques
sociales et culturelles, quitte à traiter
de très longues périodes d'un coup dans
mes vidéos. J'espère que cette approche
vous plaît parce que j'ai bien envie de continuer
de cette manière, c'est ce qui me plaît
le plus, même si ça n'exclut pas de parler
d'événements historiques parfois.
Dans cet épisode on a donc vu l'évolution
des dangers de la navigation, mais aussi les
liens avec les personnes restées au port,
l'aspect social de la mer qui impose des conditions
de vie particulière, et l'évolution de la
protection de tous les gens qui dépendent
d'elle de près ou de loin.
J'espère que cet épisode vous a plu, et
le mois prochain on devrait rester dans le
thème en abordant un autre élément naturel
et les relations entre les hommes et cet élément.
Bisous, à bientôt, abonnez-vous-partagez-allez-sur-utip-aurevoir!